hello and welcome to this
video yes the daily blitz games are back
i just um
was thinking how i can put some content
on my channel and uh
i felt that just um getting back to the
three blitz games a day is not a bad
idea
um looking at all the chess content on
youtube that is out there
this exact format is one that i
um yeah basically pioneered and nobody
does
anymore um they all do a longer
recordings mostly from twitch as they
all do
twitch which is fine it's not a
point of criticism or anything but i
just felt like what can i do
and i'm playing more blitz recently in
in recent weeks and months so
it's really not um an
issue at all to put out some daily blitz
games
so um i'm happy to get your feedback
on on this decision i try to keep them
at the three games a day as i always did
in the past
it should be possible to keep this
rate up let's say um
i have a vacation coming up which is
pretty much
it's very work heavy this vacation i
have to
write a new project but um
i try to keep the videos up even then
but we'll see what happens
if that is if that is possible so um
one thing that i need to say is that
i'm going to mix the time used for those
games a little bit
um my idea is to i'm sorry
not for not about talking about the game
too much i just want to have this
this information out i'm going to mix
the games a little bit
between the three um
most commonly used time controls
and it's going to be
five zero three plus two and three plus
two there will be some three plus two
the main reason for this decision is
that i'm
um playing in an online league
on only chess the the quarantine
quarantine i have problems with that
word leak
and they use those three time controls
and alternate between them
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
um
yeah train a little bit for for those
leaks and maybe i'm also going to put up
videos for them we'll see um
when i'm playing them i mean
so this is why i'm switching between the
time control this is a three plus two
um because at the day and i'm recording
this
the next day i have a three plus two
tournaments i'm going
to switch this around a little bit
depending on what time control
is happening like next in that leak um
okay this is not
h5 is not exactly a move that i expected
and that
okay wants to prevent knight g4 i guess
here so d5
is possible opening up
ideas like queen d4 for a discovered
attack
that is definitely possible currently
c4 is covered quite reliably
i wonder if f4 attending f5 is an
idea sometime i'm going to do it
it's not something that is completely
clear to me
d5 i didn't like so much because if he
takes he gets rookie 8 and queen f6
i can actually paint that i didn't like
that after d5
okay now f5 is
not far away
let's say from working takes rook takes
i have a check on g5 like f5 takes rook
takes
check here yeah it's not quite working
but it's close if i play d5 he takes and
i play
f5 and ending f6 this is
dangerous but he's got rookie 8
so it doesn't feel like it's working
i also have c5 sometimes
okay what does he want to do put more
pressure on that pawn
maybe this one
or better moment to play f5 i could
actually play f5 ef bishop takes h5
that's a funny idea
okay i don't have much time so i'm going
to
going to do that it's going to be a bit
dicey but
with the little time left it could be
interesting
so this one he definitely cannot take
the bishop
as queen g5 is killing
that is just too much i don't i don't
think he could uh
possibly defend that the thing is i'm
not sure that i'm threatening all that
wow really how can you defend that
that's uh tough okay so rook f5
or knight f7 they both seem to
be totally crushing knight f7 is their
counter attack no there's no check
so let's do that not sure rook f5 also
looked devastating
collapsing on f7 but this looks very
strong as well i'm just attacking the
rook also
so what is there
queen c6 maybe for no
g2 i have covered even with the rook so
he cannot even like say desperado and g2
just to get the queens off like queen c6
take their next to get queens off but
it doesn't work either rook is even
covering this so
this should be completely devastating
for black i don't see how he defends
king takes rook f5 leads to mate
i thought maybe not so
rook takes king e6
is there a way for him to defend us it's
really tough to believe
i can also take with the queen then king
e7
then that's there's a checkmate
and so this is maybe stronger yeah
i didn't see him made in the other line
like a forced mate
it looked devastating but uh
this is definitely going to be made king
e7 queen f7 mate
king g7 i check on f7 and then rook f6
for rook h6 that's over
check and now rook
f6 or
or rook f5 what's what's winning this
one
it's increment yeah so
it's important yeah it would be really
really tough now with
no increment oh got a check on g8
shoot that's a really good defense
h2 is hanging wow
what on earth king here
that was totally unnecessary
and probably i was was lost at some
point here
wow
remarkable
really remarkable yeah i have to have to
check that in analysis
yeah one reason for doing this format
again is that i can
compare to like i did the sessions um
i think it's easier to do some brief
analysis after every single game
and also people like to search by
openings in the title so
i think this is a good format now
let's have a look there we had an
english opening symmetrical
with e3 this is what i'm currently
working on in my new um
upcoming english opening repertoire for
chessable that should be out like in
october
and i'm doing more of those e3 lines
black now goes g6
d4 and with d5 puts the stick in the
center so
we get an iqp position yeah isolated
queen pawn here on d4
um this is however a very specific
iqp because after queen to b3 i'm
immediately
attacking the knight and we enter forced
play
when black um yeah has the choice
between taking on c3 and playing e6
he took on c3 and now there is his
intermediate move bishop c4
it's nice i'm attacking f7 here and
there's no way for black to save the
knight they can go here
but after bishop f7 king d7 and
queen to e6 for example i always thought
queen e6
the engine wants to castle wow yeah i
always i just knew that this one
gets the knight back and black's
position is terrible
so um yeah i have the analysis on that
is usually requested and i feel why not
so what they usually do is here not e6
but knight d5
takes and e6 which leads to this
structure this is also a little bit
better for white but
black is quite acceptable here so but he
played e6
i took here then bishop a3 is preventing
castling
so bishop f8 and we get to this position
when i think um white should should be
very slightly better i have a bit more
to play for let's say with the pawns in
the center but black is not in bad shape
i think um he was okay anyway
like here f6 okay
f6 i didn't quite consider honestly i
thought that would be to weakening
but probably this is wrong this is not a
good idea because of
h5 the knight has no squares
so i was thinking i just go back and
then i'll get e6
also i mean he will get c4 but
yeah it was a complete misjudgment
because here
what am i doing i cannot take e6 even
because of rookie 8 i guess yeah
the engine confirms and then
i'm losing this bishop here
yeah okay that would be good for black
then yeah i mean i was still not quite
focused
because of my narrative that the blit
game blitz games are back
okay i went f4 that is maybe bad then
again
now f6 f6 now
is probably very weakening yeah because
now this is maybe i can even
take on g6 which is given as an
option d5 is an interesting possibility
here
uh given by the engine that looks very
strong yeah after the knight is taken
take here
and then ready for rook d7 with
devastating effect
it's very strong yeah that's just a big
attack
the h5 move here was very weak
very weakening let's say h5 and f6 he
went queen d6 don't think that this can
be too bad
yeah rook d2 is kind of i don't know
what to do make a move
this and now i went with f5 i honestly
think
this is not so good but i wanted to do
something
yeah and it turns out to be not so good
so he takes
bishop takes and here he just has to not
take the bishop that was
more of a bluff than anything else i'm a
little bit surprised that i'm in so
terrible shape
if he yeah he can take c4 simply
i didn't see that
i was panicking a little bit with the
the time being relatively low already
it's increment i kind of forgot about
that a little bit so 40 seconds is
plenty
if you have two second extra yeah but he
cannot take it it's just a big mistake
so rook f5 is also devastating it seems
but what i did must be winning as well
would be
strange if not yeah this one
and rook takes is made yeah okay i did
not
actually see a mate um
yeah i can just win the queen yeah i
didn't see a mate here
i just looked at this king back but i
can win the queen
and that okay this is made also yeah so
i was pretty weak weak play by me
rook f5 then is much much clearer so
oops sorry so taking with the queen okay
this is also
winning but it's not as winning
now i should pick up um just h5 with
check but
okay this was a really good defense
defense try
but you know what's super stupid i'm
going to f2 here i can simply
go to h1 or f1 like
anything else but not here this is super
stupid
and now knight takes c4 oh god
well it was a really bad game rookie 8
however
gives me the win back now i'm winning
again
so okay it was a pretty awful game
for getting getting the daily blitz
games
back on the channel but yeah that's what
it is yeah
that's not every game can be beautiful
and good
okay alright guys thanks for watching